good afternoon everybody and and uh
welcome the cfar massey talk for uh
2020. one of the few good things
happening this year
actually um while we meet today on a
virtual platform i want to take a moment
to acknowledge
the indigenous peoples of all the lands
that we are on today
and the importance of the land which we
each and every one of us call home
we do this to reaffirm our commitment
and our responsibility in improving
relationships between nations
and to improve our own understanding of
local peoples
and their cultures cfar's office is in
the mars building in toronto
and is located on land that for
thousands of years
has been the traditional territory of
many nations including the euron wendat
the seneca and most recently the
mississaugas of the credit
we are grateful to have the opportunity
to work learn
and share on this land i would also
like to take this opportunity to thank
massey college
our partners in the annual cfar massey
talks this annual lecture series started
in 2015 and has become a highlight
in our calendar we have had lectures
that span disciplines from
the artificial intelligence revolution
unsolved mysteries of the cosmos
the cultural evolution and the
scientific process
itself all of these past talks are
available on cfor's youtube
channel today's event will also be
posted to that channel
in a few days the cfar massey talks are
a great opportunity
to hear about cutting-edge cutting-edge
research from seafarer fellows
and the really fresh perspectives of the
massey junior fellows who interview them
and i can assure you because i know a
lot of them the massey junior fellows
are an exceptional
really a truly exceptional group of
young people
this year we're very fortunate to have
dr jenny tong
who will be sharing how social
relationships affect us biologically
it couldn't be a more timely topic as we
have all shifted the ways we interact
over these past eight months
see far like massey is a strong believer
in the power of diversity
interdisciplinary communities of inquiry
we also believe in sharing new knowledge
we gain from science
with everybody the founders of massey
articulated that principle
i think really well by saying that they
hoped
the college would i quote nourish
learning
and serve the public good unquote
the covet 19 pandemic has highlighted
the central importance of science
research and
evidence in serving a public good
hand washing mask wearing physical
distancing new treatments vaccines
all the things that are keeping us safe
and that will finally end this pandemic
come from science the pandemic has
threatened science onto center stage
it has never been more important for all
of us in the academic
community to engage the public on the
importance and the centrality of
research
to societal well-being and i don't just
mean reeling off epidemiological
statistics or facts about vaccine
science
people want and need to trust science to
understand the scientific process
and to be part of that scientific
process
they need to feel connected to science
to hear the stories of discovery
and to see the benefits that come from
long-term investments
especially in fundamental research
for example the recent announcements
from pfizer and madurana
about mrna vaccines were only made
possible
by decades of work by a group at the
university of british columbia
i think i'm allowed to mention that
other university here
who developed lipid nanoparticles that
encapsulate the small strands of
messenger rna
and deliver them inside the body and
moderna
that was founded by one of my former
graduate students derek rossi
who developed the technology not to make
vaccines actually
but to introduce rna into cells to
reprogram them
to behave like stem cells the cfar
massey talks
are a wonderful example of exactly the
kind of
initiative that helps bring the dev
bridge the divide
and makes research more accessible to
wide
public audiences jenny tung
this year's cfar massey talk presenter
is a fellow in cfar's
child and brain development program
jenny is an associate professor in
evolutionary
anthropology and biology at duke
university in the united states
her work studying baboons and macaques
highlights
both our deep evolutionary connections
with other social species
and the critical importance of our
connections with each other
now i i am very proud to be a senior
fellow at massey college
and it is my really great pleasure
to pass the virtual microphone over to
my friend and colleague
the principal of massey college
professor nathalie de brousseau
natalie over to you merci allen
it's uh wonderful to be here with you
even so
virtually i first want to acknowledge
really uh
the great uh visionary that you are and
the role of science and articulating for
us
so often and so well the role of science
for the future of humanity and
personally i continue to be in
awe of the way in which cfar is
providing interdisciplinary
exciting relevant scientific research
that is accessible for the public so i
think we draw a lot from the model
that cfar has elaborated and continues
to
to develop for the general public
said
a second key principle of massey college
which has
uh uh alan argen described you know
nourishing learning and serving the
public good
is that we want to do it with respect
to intergenerational discussions it is
important and it's key
to the way in which messi functions that
the voices of the young researchers
are acknowledged and are celebrated and
today you will see that as well
when we will hear questions from three
junior fellows at massey college who are
phd candidates
uncle merci beaucoup
merci o doctor bernstein yeah sony kip
and enjoy the conference
hi um my name is jenny tung i'm very
honored to be a part of
the cfar massey talks series this year
and
um i want to thank all of you for uh
giving me
some of your precious time today to hear
about our work
i will go ahead and share my screen
so i'll be telling you today about some
of our work on how social relationships
get under the skin and as you might be
able to tell
from this title slide here i mostly
study this question from the perspective
of non-human social mammals um but to
motivate
um what i'll be telling you about today
i'll start with some headlines that
focus on the species that many of us
perhaps not all of us but many of us
care about the most and and that's
ourselves
as you can see here the new york times
at least has taken a regular
interest in research on what is broadly
termed the social determinants of health
those are the observations that aspects
of our social environment including
social status and our relationships with
each other are some of the most robust
predictors that we know about to date
when thinking about understanding our
health our well-being and even
the likelihood that we'll survive
through the next year
um so what's the evidence that social
determinants of health are a big deal
um there's a lot of it and i think
what's been really striking about the
past few years of research
is how we've been able to ask that
question or others have been able to ask
that question
using increasingly large data sets
so i'm showing you here an example
that's quite a remarkable data set in
part because of its size it's 1.4
billion years
of um of data but person years of data
but um also because uh many of you or at
least some of you may in fact be part of
this data set
if you um live in the united states so
this covers
anybody who has a united states social
security number
um and filed taxes and was age 40 any
time between
um the year 1999 and the year 2014
and what it shows is life expectancy as
a function
of one measure of social status
socioeconomic status in humans
which is household income at age 40.
one of the most striking things that you
can see from
from this picture is that the
relationship between
life expectancy and social economic
status
is not it turns out a function only of
severe
material deprivation but rather what
we're observing is a social gradient
in which even individuals who might have
made a hundred thousand dollars at
age 40 are expected to live years
shorter life spans
than individuals who made 200 000
so something quite profound um is going
on
to explain these kinds of patterns and
in fact um
this these kinds of observations albeit
on smaller data sets at the time
were exactly what motivated a social
epidemiologist john castle
um to say over 50 or about 50 years ago
now
um we have been accustomed to think in
terms of certain types of risk factors
right
for disease and health like nutritional
status and fatigue and overwork but
there's this entirely separate or an
entirely
additional category of environmental
factors that are capable of producing
profound
effects on host susceptibility to
disease and here the emphasis is mine
that's the presence
of other members of the same species or
more generally
certain aspects of the social
environment and as a someone who studies
um other social mammals i particularly
appreciate that he highlighted it was
other members of the same species and
not just limited to humans
more recently the sociologist lincoln
phelan
proposed that social factors such as
socioeconomic status
and social support should be viewed as
fundamental causes of disease right
um so broadly applicable in
understanding many of the types of
disorders that affect human populations
today
so i think these are really fascinating
ideas
um one of the difficulties though from
the perspective of a biologist or a life
scientist more generally
is that they don't give us a lot to hook
into in order to understand
how these kinds of observation arise
right so what we're describing
is um what is manifested manifestly
physical impacts on our bodies right
incidence of disease and the progression
of those diseases the likelihood that we
survive
and yet these kinds of ideas suggest
that
um that that social interaction is
important but don't give us a physical
mechanism to study
right they defy the sort of classic
triad between
host environment and agent that we
understand when we think about
tuberculosis or the common cold or
covid19
for example and what that means is that
despite
many many years of study there's still
um conflicting evidence
in the literature on whether social
adversity is in fact directly causal to
health and survival outcomes right that
direct arrow
in the middle there for example because
of the toxic effects of
chronic social stress whether most of
these observations are mediated
by things like health care access
or um health risk behaviors like illicit
drug
use or smoking um or
obesity or in fact whether a lot of this
is because of a reverse causal
relationship because in fact it's hard
to climb
the socioeconomic ladder it's hard to
finish an education for example
if you are chronically ill
fortunately we are not the only social
animals
on this planet and um what i'm showing
you here
are videos that show social behavior in
the four species that my lab currently
studies
so what you see on top are rhesus
macaques engaged in
affiliative grooming behavior um a
couple of
wild baboons engaged in a less friendly
interaction
which helps determine relative social
status in that species
uh wild meerkats in the kalahari desert
of south africa on the bottom left
engaged in play behavior
and de mara molerats a cooperatively be
breeding social mammal species also in
south africa
who are doing heavily cooperative
behavior they're digging tunnels to
support
the group as a whole in the interest of
time i'll tell you about some findings
from the non-human primates
above which are the species that i've
studied for the longest
okay one of the reasons that we can get
insight from these types of species that
are
that's difficult to to get from studies
of humans alone
is because we are able to watch
individually recognized
members in this case of the baboon
population that i study in kenya
on a near daily basis getting very
granular fine-grained
direct observations of their
interactions with each other
and their outcomes um from cradle to
grave
um here i'm showing you a picture of
someone doing just that this is quinoa
tere field assistant um in that works
with the project um
in kenya and has done so since 1995 so
he's a highly trained expert on the
behavior of baboons
we do this work um in the ambiselli
ecosystem of southern kenya
right on the border between kenya and
tanzania to the south
and i've been fortunate enough to do
this work in collaboration with beth
archie at the university of notre dame
susan alberts also at duke university
and gene altman
at princeton university who had the
vision of to found the long-term
research on this project
in 1971 so we're actually uh going to
celebrate our 50th anniversary
of continuous data observation on these
baboons and their descendants across
almost nine uh baboon generations just
next year
many of our major findings about the uh
social determinants of health and the
ambassador baboons
are summarized in this beautiful article
by lydia dunworth that came out um just
a couple years ago
in scientific american so if you're
interested in understanding more about
the details of your
of our work i would um refer you to this
this really lovely piece
but i'll um i'll go over some of the the
main highlights of what we found
here first we've shown
that more socially integrated baboons
both females and males
live years longer lives the most
socially integrated females in ambicelli
the ones who engage in the most
affiliated behavior and have the closest
social bonds
end up living lives that are often two
to three years longer on
average than those who are relatively
socially isolated and if we do the sort
of
conversion of baboon years to human
years sort of like dog years to human
years
um which is more familiar to many that
translates into a difference of about
six to
nine years so that's a big difference in
the lives of these animals
in addition we found that social
relationships seem to be worth competing
over
so female baboons live longer if they're
more socially integrated with other
females
and there's an independent effect of
greater social
bonds greater social bond strength with
adult males
but only the highest ranking females
tend to be able to form those
relationship with males
suggesting that just like diet or good
sleeping sites
or mates social relationships have
become
resources that are worth buying over for
these females
additionally our research has been
revealing
some complex relationships between
social status
and downstream outcomes high social
status is in general positive for these
animals again it allows them to compete
successfully over resources
but whereas high social status in
females seems to be productive
um from things like uh inflammation
chronic inflammation
in the in the blood blood samples from
these animals
high status in males which has to be
attained through direct physical
competition
actually seems to translate to somewhat
higher inflammatory profiles
and a little bit elevated mortality risk
suggesting that when we try to
understand the relationship
between social status on one hand and
downstream health and survival outcomes
on the other
we have to pay a lot of attention to how
social status is actually attained and
maintained
in the particular societies we're
interested in in this case
males have to do it through direct
physical competition
i mean in maintenance of um of
good body condition whereas female
baboons are doing it through nepotistic
means through kinship ties
perhaps more similar to what we see in
many human societies
um additionally we've been heavily
motivated by interacting with social
scientists
who are really the experts on the social
determinants of health
to ask questions about how social
adversity particularly in early life
might translate to long-term outcomes in
the animals that we study
so inspired by some of the work in the
social sciences we asked a simple
question a few years ago
which is simply how the aggregate
experience of early life adversity for
baboons
in our population individuals who might
have lost their mothers earlier been
born to low status families
or had relatively socially isolated
early life experiences
affected how long they lived in this
completely unmanipulated unmanaged
natural population surprisingly to us
there was an incredibly strong
effect of cumulative early life
adversity on
at lifespan outcomes even years to
decades later
what i'm showing you here is evidence
that baboon females
who experience no early life adversity
the animals that we call
sort of silver spoon females could live
you know an expected lifespan of 18 to
20 years if they made it to adulthood
on the other hand animals who
experienced three or more sources of
early life adversity
who were born to socially isolated or
low status mothers
or in drought environments or lost their
mothers early
lived on average less than 10 years so
here we're talking about a difference of
a decade or more
a huge difference if you think about it
in human terms
more recently we've been able to show
that these kinds of effects percolate
across generations so here we watched
those
females who experienced major early life
adversity in this case early
maternal loss as they grew up and had
offspring of their own so here i'm
circling in red that we're looking at
their own offspring surviving
a generation later and what we find
is that for those females who
experienced adversity in their own early
lives
as adults their own offspring did not
survive as well through the juvenile
period
as the offspring of mothers who were you
know in those sort of silver spoon
um conditions suggesting that the
effects of early adversity
especially social adversity mediated by
mothers
has this profound intergenerational
effect that can last
many decades after the original insult
occurred
together we think the evidence from
baboon suggests that the social
determinants health of health
have pretty deep roots in our
evolutionary history
right um although i am absolutely sure
that um mediators like healthcare access
and health risk behaviors have important
consequences
for human health even when we remove
those types of explanations as we do
in this natural baboon population that
we study
we still see quite strong
remarkably strong really effects of the
social environment on things like
natural lifespan in fact at last count
in at least 13 different socially social
mammal species separated by
tens of million years of evolutionary
time
we observe relationships between the
quality of individual social
relationships
and uh and how long individuals
again suggesting really profound old
ties between sociality and health
that motivates using other species as
sources of insight
into what's going on in our own species
who is affected
when they're affected and how those
effects arise finally i want to tell you
a little bit about why
i'm fairly confident that at least some
of these relationships actually do arise
from a causal pathway
where social adversity is causal to
downstream health outcomes
if we want to understand causality as
many of us learned in our science
classes
in grade school the best way to do it
the gold standard approach is to do an
experiment right what we do is
manipulate variable
x and then watch what happens to
variable y but for reasons that are
probably very obvious to you
we can't do long-term experimentally
controlled manipulations
of the social environment in humans and
we can't do those types of experiments
in wild baboons either
but in captive primates we can do some
of these types of
experiments to ask about what changes in
the social environment alone
does to our bodies or to the bodies of
these animals
we can do that in the species that i'm
showing you here
rhesus mccats because in adult female
macaques all you have to do
is put them into new social groups with
one another to manipulate
the social status hierarchy okay so um
individuals who were introduced earlier
tend to be highest ranking in those
social hierarchies and as we introduce
females sequentially one by one
they sort of slot into that social
ladder directly below the animals who
came in before
so we can make these new social groups
and we can replicate them across social
groups
to watch what happens when we control
order of introduction
we can even do a secondary experiment
where we say take all the alpha females
together
after a year and put them in the same
social group and all the betas and so on
and then watch a new social hierarchy
form
which allows us to ask about what
happens to an individual
when she is for example high in the
hierarchy and low in the hierarchy and
vice versa so this really gives us
very strong um insight
into causal relationships what we found
is that manipulating social status per
se even when we control diet and
healthcare access and all those other
sorts of things
has profound impacts on how the immune
system
works in these animals and even further
um has an effect on how the immune
system does its job how it responds
to stimuli provided by say bacteria or
viruses
we can do that because we can just draw
blood from these animals
into tubes that contain basically cell
food
for a few hours or tubes that contain
you know food for those cells plus
a bacteria or plus a viral stimulus and
then we can measure
the activity of all the genes in the
genome from paired samples from each of
these individuals
challenge ex vivo so this is a
complicated diagram
but i think um all i want you to pay
attention to is that there's a lot of
blue and there's a lot of purple
highlighting aspects of proteins in our
cells that are important
to the response to bacteria and virus in
fact this
top dot that lps label dot is the
stimulus
that we give these cells and what we
find is that animals who
are low status tend to preferentially
activate
one type of immune pathway in response
to this bacterial-like stimulus
that creates a lot of an in a strong
inflammatory response
whereas animals who are assigned to this
high ranking status
actually use preferentially an
alternative pathway in the cell
in other words by manipulating social
status aspects of the social environment
alone we causally alter immune function
including the immune response to
bacteria and virus so the stimulus that
is happening on the level of
interactions between individuals
actually reaches deep into our cells to
affect
molecular signaling occurring at this
subcellular level
and perhaps most profoundly we found
that even when social status changes
when we do those sequential shifts
of the social hierarchy a genomic
signature of social history remains
in other words we can look at those
cells and we can measure gene activity
and actually tell you
something about what happened in that
animal's
social interactions over a year previous
in their past so one way to think about
that is that even our cells
carry kind of a signature of what
their experience has been like our cells
carry baggage from their interactions
past
okay so i want to conclude by um
um thinking back to the motivating
examples i provided in the beginning
which largely come from the social
sciences outside the domain of the life
sciences
but what i hope you'll take away from
what i've presented to you so far
is that there is um fairly strong
evidence
that um that those types of interactions
those types of relationships
can nevertheless have
profound effects on the level of our
biology
or the biology of social mammals and
therefore we can use biological tools
and biological perspectives
to understand the social determinants of
health both through the deep time lens
of evolution
and also by using molecular and
physiological analyses to understand
uh mechanism so in other words the
social is in fact biological we don't
have to think about social behavior as a
separate phenomenon
than the things that actually um affect
our our bodies on a quite profound level
um so with that i want to thank the
the many people who have allowed this
work to happen my close collaborators
susan alberts jean altman and beth
archie on the baboon work
and my collaborators louis barrero mark
wilson and basmacopoulos
on the macaques as well as the members
of my lab and our funding agencies
and all of you for um your attention and
willingness to share a part of your day
with me
um so thank you very much and i'm happy
to um start a discussion with the with
the nasty fellows
great thank you so much jenny for uh for
a really fascinating presentation
um you know it's really great to get a
better sense of of you know
how social relationships are you know
are more than uh if you will skin deep
um and you know how how they can shape
these sorts of risk factors for
uh you know the etiology of disease and
and conditions and so on so
um to briefly introduce myself uh my
name is richael nike
and i'm an msc student in global health
policy at the university of toronto
and a junior fellow at massey college uh
my colleagues and i
are really excited to uh ask a few more
questions and to learn a bit more
um about your work and this idea of the
social determinants of health as we
understand them
you know using the tools of biology uh
so to really briefly
uh you know start off um i'd like to
take a step back and and
kind of ask about your life course um
you know and the pathway along it you
know what
uh you know what sort of events have
shaped uh you know the work you do now
and and and sort of how you entered
uh you know the field and the field work
you get to do
yeah so um my my path and my research
interests have taken some twists and
turns i
i knew early on actually in in college
as a consequence of
being fortunate enough to take a class
that had an interdisciplinary focus
that i was interested in evolutionary
biology that i thought
genetics and genomics in particular were
the currency through which evolution
worked and so i wanted to integrate that
into my life somehow
and that i was particularly interested
in um
sort of the individually differentiated
social interactions that you know
at least to my mind are what largely
affects um
how we do from day to day i had
um no training and no exposure to
thinking about
um you know how we do from day to day as
something that compounded to influence
how we did over the life course
but i was fortunate enough again to be
hired in my current job through an
interdisciplinary search that
gave me exposure to people working on
biodemography and social relationships
from the perspective of sociology and
psychology and social epidemiology
and so on and um i have to say
that that interaction
both um you know gave me and my labs and
collaborators just new
ideas about how to frame things because
this is there's this sort of
almost entirely independent trajectory
of pretty amazing
science um that was also interested in
individually differentiated social
relationships and what their
consequences were for
um the life course what we call life
history right in in
in the biological sciences but you know
what what they think about as
you know health and well-being and
survival
so a bunch of new ideas and also sort of
an opportunity to take my
my long-term interests in behavior and
evolution and genetics
and think about um framing them to an
audience in ways that might
take my interest in very basic research
and think about how they might be useful
in some small way
right to people who are really focused
on the health and well-being of our own
species something that you know i've
become increasingly interested in over
time
thanks jenny um my name is mariella i'm
a phd candidate in cell and systems
biology
and moving a bit from the back end of
your history into kind of the background
of your talk
i um the next question is you know given
that interactions can be
costly to an individual's health um you
know social systems kind of seem
a little bit evolutionarily this in
other words
maybe a bad deal so then why do we see
them in the world
and what is the benefit of a social
system in terms of fitness and
evolutionary success
and what sorts of environments would we
see these really start to arise
yeah so uh that's a really fascinating
question and of course you know
not all species are social i happen to
study obligately social species and
we happen to be pretty much an
obligately social species right
and so i think the costs that um you
know that i alluded to and that you're
you're talking about here
relate to once you're once you're an
obligate social species what are the
costs to
you know be having a short under the
stick right or
you know being relatively socially
isolated or being relatively
low status within that society
um i think they don't speak
to why we started doing this in the
first place and there's some really good
good reasons right if you happen to be a
diurnal species you happen to live
during the day
and you look like really tasty to a
large predator
being around other con specifics other
members of the same species is a really
good idea and we think that was a really
strong selection pressure
that guided the origins of sociality for
example in primates you actually
see this shift diurnality to living in
the daytime and making your life in the
daytime and all of a sudden you see
these social aggregations right
social aggregations also are really
beneficial
when there's a lot of competition
between other members of the same
species right
so if i'm going to compete with other
humans or if i'm a baboon and i'm going
to compete with other baboons for the
same types of resources and so on
then i would really like to have the
support
made available by you know cooperating
with other individuals in sort of
resource defense and sort of things
so there's some really good reasons for
this and i actually think
a lot of oop wow
sorry about that a lot of the costs um
of being socially isolated have to do
with um i'm speculating here right but
have to do
with our body telling us that is not
what we're supposed to be
doing right this is this is this creates
vulnerabilities
that's why that's why there's such um
there's such strong evidence for chronic
social stress associated with social
isolation
even when you know as far as we can tell
we're meeting our basic needs
for food and shelter and so on it turns
out that those social relationships are
basic needs once they become basic needs
um that uh failure to fulfill them
is is problematic for us
yeah wonderful answer um
so in your talk you mentioned some of
the non-human animal systems that you
use to study these and model systems in
general and so
i was wondering if you could just sort
of quickly define what is a model system
in this case
and then talk a bit about some of the
benefits
that we get from using model systems to
study humans and particularly using
different model systems in concert
sort of the power of uniting all these
different things
yeah that's a great question so i'm
using model system pretty loosely in the
sense that i think that we can learn
something
about um the human condition from
studying these other
types of species and you know some of
the reasons to
to do that i hope um came through some
of the examples i provided today which
is
you know we can we can start answering
questions about whether
our reliance on um on social relations
for the connections between social
relationships and health and humans are
something that
we have managed to innovate in our own
society right you know
you see a lot of um of stuff about how
we live in very different kinds of
environments than we did previously that
we have elaborated notions
of social stratification far beyond
anything that any other animal
has come up with and so maybe this is
just you know
something that's a weird um outgrowth
of our um very derived societies
especially our sort of modern societies
where
we may live far from kin and and live in
very
large urban environments and so on i
think studying
other social animals makes it clear that
that is not the whole story that cannot
be the whole story
and in fact we were social before we
were human
right we were probably social before the
great apes emerged on
our our planet right our our close
relatives right
and so part of the reason that we are
likely sensitive to social conditions
um in addition to the structures that we
have built up as
you know uh you know very encephalized
smart creative and sometimes
self-destructive species is because
we have been sensitive to our social
environments our forebears have been
sensitive to social environments for
millions of years
so there's that that general proof of
principle that we can get from studying
other species
there's also the fact that with other
species we can sometimes do
the types of manipulative experiments
that are just impossible to do in our
own species right it's never going to be
ethical or feasible to just randomize
income or educational attainment or
you know social social integration
across individuals in human societies
but we can do that
to really try and understand the causal
pathways that connect
our social environment to downstream
outcomes that's really a powerful thing
that we can use models for human social
environments or social behavior for and
then i think um a third thing and this
relates to your question about the
diversity
of social structures that you find in
different types of species
um i i think we can use that diversity
in a way that's
actually a very common tactic for
evolutionary biologists and for
behavioral ecologists
to understand what exactly it is about
say social hierarchies that matter
you know we use social status and social
hierarchies to describe the organization
of
a lot of species but in species like
baboons and macaques
and us when we talk about social
hierarchies we talk about
we're talking about hierarchies that
involve
you know priority of access to resources
and that
include individuals that might be your
relatives but actually often aren't your
relatives that you don't have any
you know reason to um to help out
because of kin ties
right so lots of individuals a lot of
them not relatives living in a group
together
in social hierarchies but in other
species like cooperative breeders
you know social status really means that
you're breeding versus not breeding
right it's a very different
aspect of biology that defines
hierarchies
and by comparing across those types of
species we can understand
you know what exactly it is that creates
these kinds of consequences for health
and i think we're starting to see that
picture emerge
as people study aspects of social
relationships in animals
as diverse as you know marmots or rodent
other primates dolphins whales
and so on we also see a lot of variation
in
in terms of the strictness and stability
of social hierarchies which
which i think probably matter right are
is this fixed across your entire life or
across generations
or is it really fluid depending on
aspects of competition
you know humans are really remarkable in
the sense that you know we
have done pretty much any every every
version you can come up with is
something that human
societies have um have innovated
um the the nature of social
relationships tends to be much simpler
and much more stereotyped in other
species but we can cover the diversity
in humans or much of the diversity in
humans
and perhaps more by looking at the um
you know tens of millions or hundreds of
millions if you want to go out to like
you know fish and use social insects and
so on
of evolutionary time that um that nature
affords us
so that comparative perspective is one
of the things that
you know evolutionary biologists and
biology in general go back to that well
over and over as a source of insight but
i think it's been until fairly recently
a little underutilized and trying to
understand these kinds of effects of
the social environment it's really
interesting to kind of hear
sort of the the scientific principles
and then sort of the precepts that
uh that that entail uh you know working
at a you know from a comparative
approach and and kind of hearing from
you know multiple
species and that sort of thing um you
know to maybe the other direction
on gaby's question um is there anything
that that gets lost in translation uh
you know when we're studying
uh non-human primates and then and then
applying those lessons to
uh to human systems and you know when we
talk about the social determinants of
health you know as you mentioned
we're talking about structures um you
know is there
you know how does that translate in a in
a non-human biological sense
other species are great great sources of
insight for us but there are some things
that i think don't translate very well
um and one of them is the fact that all
the solar social interactions and
measures of
social integration and social status
that i alluded to early life adversity
and so on
are consequences in other species
of interactions between individuals who
live in the same social group like they
know each other
right we know about their social
direction because they are like
physically interacting with each other
on a day-to-day basis
um in humans we're able to define
social hierarchies and establish forms
of social integration with people that
we have
never met and will never meet right when
we think about social hierarchies
defined for example by
income you know i can compare myself to
you know jeff bezos unfavorably
um and you know we're never going to
interact directly
right and so there's sort of a
limitation of scale
and what we can do with other species um
in translating back and forth to humans
right so we there are also other things
that i think um
are simply difficult to study in other
species that
are important that are really important
in thinking about the social
determinants of health in humans
um for example concepts like stigma
um uh racial and ethnic prejudice
um and also just sort of generally
subjective measures of
social isolation or well-being are much
more difficult
to figure out how to model in
um in other species so we can do a
pretty good job
of sort of general um
socially induced stress right and we can
we can measure
social subordination and we can measure
social isolation pretty well but there's
some pretty complicated constructs in
humans
related to the social determinants of
health that are
possibly beyond what we can get at
directly by studying other species
yeah there's a they're always at the
limit right and i think that
that probably the
sort of message i'm trying to get out
there
is not that we will like this will solve
everything that you know by using
biological perspectives
um which can be you know brought to bear
even in studies of humans
but particularly biological perspectives
and animals we're not going to solve
everything
but you know social structuring
of our lives and our health and our
well-being is such
an important part of understanding both
sort of the human experience but also
you know whether we get sick and whether
we survive
that you know if this were anything if
this is we think about cancer or heart
disease or whatever you bring
every every strategy that
um science has to bear on those
questions
and i think we haven't done that here
but we could do more of it
no individual strategy is going to be a
silver bullet
thank you um so to go back to the
beginning of your talk you mentioned
that as humans we love to learn about
ourselves and another thing that all
humans like to think is that we're all
unique
um so in your work have you at all
looked at um individual
variability um so how susceptible
different individuals are to stress
and how this will then impact both
positive and negative negative
relationships in
later life yeah so that is a question
that we are very actively interested in
um this is something that i think feels
very familiar to ourselves when we think
about our own species but it's true for
baboons and macaques and
you know i would i would wager every
other
social species where the social
environment is important is that not all
not all of us not all of them respond to
the same kinds of adversity in the same
kind of way
so we're pretty interested in the degree
for example to which
um social relationships in adulthood
might be able to buffer the consequences
of early life adversity right can
can you manage to um you know
recover from those kinds of early
insults through other aspects of the
social environment later in life
um we're quite interested in
the degree to which um
possibly different genetic differences
among individuals
influence their resilience to these
types of
types of insults that we study um so for
example do
particular so we know that genetic
differences
influence the immune response to
pathogens right to some degree
does that interact with the social
environment which we believe also
influences the immune response to
pathogens in a way
that produces um better predicted
outcomes for those responses those are
things that we're
we're quite interested in now but um
don't have a lot of answers for yet
unfortunately
that's really cool topic um and then
you're like also just with regard like
you're talking about
can we buffer those uh early life um
that early life adversity in later life
in that same sense can
those uh these changes that are probably
you know like epigenetically occurring
are they heritable are they
transgenerational
yeah so um we're quite interested in the
epigenetic signatures of early adversity
and we've been doing some work on that
now um none of which is is
published yet but what what it looks
like to us is that different sources of
adversity have different
you know sort of long-term effects and
in fact um
yeah so i'll just say that what i will
also say though is that
we think some of the intergenerational
consequences we're looking at are
probably
don't require epigenetic explanations
for example
i mentioned that um females who
experience maternal loss early in their
lives right
they grow up and they have poor survival
of their own infants
right and that tends to particularly be
driven
by cases where those infants were born
um
within a short time span before that
female that mom
the one who actually experienced
maternal loss early in her life died
right and so our best interpretation of
that
is actually that females who experience
major early life adversity have
somewhat compromised poorer body
condition throughout their lives
and as a consequence of that poor body
condition they're less able to
successfully raise their own offspring
right so there's kind of this direct
effect that doesn't necessarily
require sort of more complicated
um uh you know epigenetic mediators even
though
epigenetic mediators may play a role in
in why those females look you know like
they're in worse condition than others
so we're getting this intergenerational
effect i don't think we need to
implicate
um a complicated epigenetic inheritance
mechanism
it's really interesting that that you
know we can we don't even have to look
you know you know below um you know to
the epigenetic sort of pathways to kind
of just get a sense of what kinds of
effects
that sort of adversity can have um you
know if we if we look at a
you know maybe at a population level you
know do you have you know any sort of
insights as to to
you know whether that adversity is
experienced uh you know through the
relationship or
uh you know or in the genome um you know
on this idea of social cohesion and some
of the conflict that we might observe
you know in
uh in human populations between human
communities you know um
within us um you know between our groups
um
do you have any takes on on on that so
it's not work that we've done
so far um partly because when you start
looking at the effects of social groups
as a whole like what are the dynamics of
the social group as a whole
you know basically just from a straight
brass tax perspective you drop sample
size like crazy
from samples in the space of individuals
to samples in the space of societies or
social groups
but there's some really interesting work
by other people um brenda mccowan at uc
davis is
is someone i can think of um off the bat
who
has who've been interested in how uh
sort of conflict or or frequent conflict
at a social group level
influences the development of of young
rhesus macaques right
and so there there is some literature
out there suggesting that
um you know what's going on maybe not
directly involving you right directly
involving an individual
in early life but what's sort of going
on in the environment having to do with
social conflict or social cohesion
might be an important um component of
sort of exposure
form of social adversity cool
so obviously like in the midst of this
pandemic in covet 19 we're all really
changing how we interact with people
and how we are social um
and so i was wondering if you could
speak to maybe a little bit how
social isolation and how it affects us
changes across
different ages and how covert in
particular might be affecting
um our young people our old people in
particular ways and what this means
going forwards
yeah so um there's a beautiful
meta-analysis published by julian holt
lundstadt and colleagues about 10 years
ago
that attempt to quantify social
isolation versus social integration
social support versus lack of it right
two different kind of dimensions
that connect um on awkward mortality
right basically dying for any reason
excluding suicide
and one of the interesting things that
came out of that meta-analysis they
brought together
like 150 different studies to try and
estimate these effects
is that um greater social isolation
had a pretty similar effect on
increased mortality rates about a 50
increase in all-cause mortality rates
across both men and women um
this was data from multiple countries
although primarily um
you know sort of western um uh developed
uh
societies um and that was pretty
constant
across the life course too right so you
just get this
sort of 50 percent bump for being you
know relatively socially isolated versus
relatively socially connected
and that's steady of course one of the
the the big differences between young
people and old people
is that you know age is the biggest risk
factor for mortality that we know of
right
and so a 50 increase um will be is going
to be really visible
right for elderly parts of our
population
relative to you know young people in our
populations at least on the short term
and so even though the the sort of
relative increase may be the same i
think
um the immediate outcomes are are are
worse
right for for people who are older
i think it's a different kind of
question um especially because other
comorbidities right
come into play more for for for older
people too if we're talking about covid
i think another aspect of your question
though is like what's the what's the
cost of this long term
and you know i don't think we know the
answer to that yet
what we know is that um
we are experiencing you know sort of a
society-wide um insult
right social environmental insult that
is likely to have long-term consequences
on you know individuals who are children
right now
right who are experiencing early life
and i don't really think we're going to
know the outcomes until much later in
life but i can already
you know see you know sometime in the
future maybe 30 years from now the cfar
massey lecture right
people will be talking about how
shutdowns happened at different periods
of time in different societies in
different parts of the country
and how that can be used right to try
and understand the causal relationships
between the effects of those shutdowns
and um downstream health outcomes right
that's a that's a natural experiment of
sorts that we're all living nobody wants
to live through a natural experiment but
we happen to be
living through one now and i think it
has the potential in
a small silver lining to tell us a lot
about how
exposure to relative social isolation
at different stages of the life course
matter to long-term outcomes
so it's not an answer but it is a you
know
a prediction that we will ultimately
learn a lot
from from what we're all going through
now
i think that's a great prediction um you
know and and
you know to the to the point of um you
know the isolation we're experiencing
um you know we're getting to use mediums
you know like this
uh you know uh technology you know
offers a lot of
opportunities for us to connect in new
ways um does
does that you know ameliorate uh some of
the the conditions that that isolation
can have that you know you point to in
earlier studies
um or can it exacerbate them and you
know do we really even know
at this point well um if i'm wearing my
sort of scientist hat i will say i don't
know
i don't know you know and other people
may know better than
than i do who've been you know sort of
studying that question about the degree
to which
um you know internet technology can
can substitute for direct social
interactions
um so if i take off my scientist head i
just put on my you know this is my own
experience hat i guess i would say
you know it's better than nothing having
this opportunity to interact with you
and have this conversation
is is far better than than having that
cut off entirely
but i think we all can recognize or most
of us recognize that it's
it's not quite the same so that is
that is my off-label non-scientist
reflection
um on this experience so jenny and
and uh junior fellows on the call i'm
going to jump in here there's a lot of
really great questions actually in the
in the q a room
um i'm going to choose one because i
don't think we have time for any more of
them and you the question about
the um the impact of kovid uh john
godfrey asked that question
actually um but i'm going to go up to
the very first question
at least on my list from a beverly
biederman it's about
people who have survived the holocaust
[Music]
one can't imagine a more traumatic
experience than that
and she makes the point that a number of
them i don't know what the proportion is
really go on to live long lives and and
kind of robust
lives um jenny do you have any any
thoughts i'm not asking you for an
explanation but any thoughts about that
in terms of adversity and and the life
course
well i think that you know this relates
to one of mariella's earlier questions
which is that
people experience you know what looks to
us like the same
sort of um you know adverse experience
right and we don't all respond in the
same way
and one of the things that i think is a
real frontier for this area that we
really need to understand better
is what predicts why some people respond
better than
others right you know where some
survivors more able to tap
into social networks right afterwards
that
that promoted resilience were some
individuals um you know
because of their experience prior to the
horror of the holocaust
more resilient because they came into it
in a different
kind of place than others um i will say
that when we're talking about
you know so the search examples i gave
you from my own work involve
things that are you know that are uh
you know bad for for example baby
baboons but you know sort of
things that happen as a routine course
of baboons lives
events like the holocaust are far far
more extreme
um and i i don't know the degree to
which we can
we can go back so with that caveat that
i don't know how much we can extrapolate
back and forth in terms of mechanism and
explanations
i will also say that um in the early
adversity literature or the early life
effects
literature in in animals people also
talk a lot about viability selection and
viability selection
translates again to you know individuals
come in
different to the experience and those
individuals who survive
a very very difficult experience are
often
those who are particularly strong for
whatever whatever reason um coming into
it and that may also account for some of
the
sort of um observations book by tom
voyce who used to be the co-director of
the child and brain development program
called the orchard the orchid and the
dandelion
speaking to the extreme differences in
resilience
between some children who experience
adversity
uh they're the sort of the robust ones
they're the dandelions and the ones who
are very
uh not very resilient the opposite
spectrum and the end of the spectrum and
they're the orchest
and exactly as you said what what is the
basis for that difference and
and resilience between those two
extremes and everything in between of
course
yeah absolutely unfortunately it's my
job to
have to end this i think we could go on
for a long time more this has been just
such a fascinating conversation so i
want to thank you jenny for
kind of setting the stage and sharing
with
all of us just a wonderful uh your work
just it's just wonderful to hear about
sort of bridging this gap or this divide
between anthropology biology
um at uh early life events and the
socio-economic determinants of health it
just was a real treat
uh sort of our lunch treat uh uh and the
three uh junior fellows mariella rashee
and gavia who uh
as i expected would do a great job in
keeping a conversation going
around a really important as well as
fascinating topic
um i also want to thank um uh massey
college of course and natalie for
uh this great partnership uh between us
and and
really i think uh bringing to a wider
audience
uh really important science that's not
just important for the people studying
it like
like you jenny but for all of us and
this is a great example
of that and the questions in that
there's now seven questions in the chat
box that are each of them
really uh fascinating so i apologize to
those of you who didn't get to their
questions
rachel parker who's a senior director in
our research group
uh really put this together uh and
invited jenny i think so
jenny and rachel thank you very much
all of this happens seamlessly sort of
and doesn't happen on its own it's not
sort of uh
you know entropy gets in the way uh but
uh the reason it doesn't happen in a
chaotic way is because of our events
team at cfar and it's jackie sullivan
wendy
helly and her colleagues uh has really
done a super job
in and not just this event but our whole
series of events
on on really important areas of science
so
thank you and to all of you who have
been here uh and very
i think diligently listened for the hour
uh at uh jenny's talk in the
conversation afterwards uh
you know thank you and stay safe
everybody and um
again thank everybody for your
participation and really a very very
fascinating hour
thank you thank you so much
you